you doing yes sir I'm sure how can we
help you okay well my daughter is having
a really bad season while she's being
treated for acid reflux and they really
don't know what it okay how old is she
sure how old is he
she's 18 years old mm-hmm okay
she's about 140 pounds before you know
any other issues any diabetes have a
pressure arthritis I know she's only 18
years old buddy that other stuff
no they checked over bloodwork
everything came back okay no and no
asthma no asthma and bronchitis no skin
problems or eczema dermatitis No okay
good this is a fairly simple set for a
couple months
okay any more okay well listen up here
we go
Charmaine you there I'm here okay here's
a young lady 18 years old has acid
reflux is diagnosed by the doctors
what's going on here well she has a lack
of a siddhis what the problem is
yes you got a girl eight plus okay lack
of acid and what would you do what would
you do for her and help her support the
healthy digestion and avoid all this
reflux stuff well I never get on a
gluten-free diet and I would have her
take a healthy I get her to take a
healthy well she could take a how the
digestive packs got everything in it
that she would need mm-hmm the enzymes
and everything okay well the enzymes of
course the ultimate enzymes which have
stomach acid in it and what happens is
when you don't have enough stomach acid
and this can be caused by restricting
salt you know if your daughter really is
obsessive about restricting salt Dave no
she no I mean I've kind of put her on a
Whole Foods
you know Roth a lot of raw foods now yes
okay okay no we don't have a lot of time
here so she needs to Psalter food to
taste and in addition to the healthy
digestive pack char and make sure she's
using one or two of those
enzymes - for each meal a couple hours
of water what would you give her to deal
with all the bloating and pain and
nausea that goes along with acid reflux
I'll never get the peppermint oil from
our ancient legacy yeah our Roman
therapy division including ancient leg
Zeke and never get those little 10 ml
bottles of peppermint you might need a
couple of the months but five drops of
the peppermint all in a coffee a couple
of hot water or one of our great teas
okay Arica live teas and how quickly can
you see that bloating and pain go down
Jermaine about 10 seconds also we you
know we have the dots where the little
you there little involved yeah